what's up et I'm bringing you to the set
of my new music video one thought away
here's an exclusive look alright we're
getting ready their makeup and
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're hearing Camarillo Airport we're
doing this really epic music video where
a sure he's texting his girl and he
can't really connect with her he ends up
passing out and having this epic dream
where he thinks of Wiz Khalifa picks him
up on a jet it's not her shot
the party
Jane the back money less cash we're
doing like these epic shots on a runway
big dance sequence the choreography is
off the chain there's like a lot of
saucy Beaumont's with him and Andy
together one thought away is like to me
it's basically about this girl that I
just can't get off my mind and when I'm
not with her you know I don't feel right
and when I went there I feel like you
know the whole world stops and we're
just you know only two people left in
the world and
because this is the fun you know it's
fun summer song we got the best director
this guy male I love him and I didn't
beat us to the video so it's gonna be
epic
[Music]
hold it hold it hold it hold it there
just hold it
cut yeah that's a wrap et1 thought of
A&E with Blanc Wiz Khalifa go check it
out you know I love you guys
ah
[Music]
[Applause]